uh this year
and when this game finishes we're going
to show you magnus's stats and i have a
feeling it's more than 40 hours for the
world champion and here we go game two
magnus carlsen is up by one point has
the white pieces here and what are we
seeing it's the queen's gambit
magnus may be inspired by the netflix
show but also just very standard stuff
very common opening and it's the queen's
gambit declined not accepting the gambit
and uh black not taking white's pawn
there in the center just solidifying his
structure
how will magnus respond he brings his
knight out magnus making a bit of a face
there i think again it's a bit like the
last game the opening stages might be a
bit cagey
and i'm kind of curious as to what move
artemief has in mind whether this was i
was going to ask this question whether
he will repeat what he played against uh
shakira mama jarov and that was to
challenge immediately in the center and
it has happened
so
in that particular game mamijarov
actually responded with porn takes pawn
there it is
and uh after pawn takes pawn then he
simply developed the knight
gains back the bishop next turn with a
check and a double attack hitting the
white king and hitting the white knight
and okay we might be headed towards a
very similar position but first magnus
is going uh on the attack he's playing
pawn takes pawn he's going after black's
central pawn and now we definitely
expect the central pawn to step forward
it's attacked twice by white's knight
and white by the white queen and uh if
the black pawn does step forward as it
does we might see a transposition into
the line we just showed white's knight
now has to run away
and looking ahead at my database the
play gets wild
so for instance
black's most popular move like this
they're smiling in anticipation of that
wildness about to happen maybe you just
have to look at art
he's laughing really hard how's that
tell me a frozen yeah that's what i'm
wondering disconnected oh